so i'm thinking about so we've got this
food shortage coming
and um let me see if i if i have this
story yeah here we go new york post says
record diesel prices could lead to food
shortages in u.s farmers warn
so i'm thinking about this and there was
a post from uh was it pawn all the
things a twitter account saying that
like lebanon and um
kazakhstan all the other states get a
majority of their wheat from and crops
from ukraine and russia
now they're not getting that food and so
i thought what's going to happen
inside those countries
when they don't get food
i think
my opinion is lebanon will attack
another country to get food
possibly i mean i think you're also
going to see begging for for foreign aid
and that foreign aid is going to come in
and probably say for sure things will
have to get really bad before people
start going to war but the u.s is
looking at major shortages as well we
are that's what people need to
understand about the food shortage it is
not just that we don't have fertilizer
we didn't have fertilizer because of the
war in ukraine with russia that
dramatically cut our fertilizer down
they were reporting crop yields would be
down 40 percent
then you have hyperinflation already the
economy's in trouble so food is going to
be more expensive less readily available
then what people don't understand is
that this story right here farmers need
diesel to get the crops no kidding so
now if the gas is in short supply six
bucks a gallon three times more than it
was last year and there's less food as
it was
your loaf of bread is gonna be 20 bucks
it's going to get expensive i will say
that with i'll give you one little white
pill though which is that these
industries some of the people who move
in these industries can make
technological advances really rapidly
the that will con that will hinge on
whether or not the federal government
administration the agencies really the
federal agencies allow them to do that
and we saw them do it really rapidly
you know set aside
testing requirements for
certain types of drugs that came out
over the last couple of years i would
hope that they would do the same
when it comes to food i don't know but
it's possible so norman borlaug is the
scientist who i think he quadrupled crop
yield for like wheat and some other
crops
however uh i was reading about this i
could be wrong because i'm not
going to pretend to be an agricultural
expert
the crop yield increased but the
nutritional density did not
so that meant that there was a large
amount of starch available but not
enough vitamins so one of the arguments
made as to why poor people are so fat
is because in order to get the same
amount of folate or thiamine or you know
whatever b vitamins you've got to eat
four times as much heavy grains than you
used to so poor people trying to get the
nutritional value are eating massive
amounts of starch gaining fat yes so
well
i'm not i don't think i should call
myself an insider this i will tell you
that my boyfriend works in agriculture
agriculture tech and one of the things
that he talks about a lot that i've seen
is that soil health is getting improved
okay and that is a really good thing to
know and what that also means is that
they're going to become less reliant
upon antibiotics
and industrial fertilizer and things
like that so it is it is possible but
again there are a lot of regulatory
hurdles and it would take a lot of work
to get everybody implementing these
practices really rapidly but it is
technically possible and if it's
technically possible then i'm going to
be optimistic and i'm going to be like
mary and be like yay that's not going to
happen here yeah i'm not optimistic i
just think nothing ever happens and
everything's fake okay
i hear you a form of optimism
in a way yeah we're going to spin that
for you well okay that's there's two
biases there's a normal c bias and the
optimism bias yeah normalcy is what
you're saying nothing ever happens it
won't happen and optimism is
good things are going to happen it can't
be that's too bad right
i skew optimistic
uh i don't i don't know if if optimism
is the right way to look at it because
um or pessimistic it's like positive or
negative it's a thing that's happening
yeah i want to be realistic but exactly
but part of my realism is acknowledging
that i skew slightly optimistic yeah
there's the logic of it which is a
realistic thing or fantasy and then
there's the
emotional aspect of it which is optimism
or pessimism and you can be a realistic
optimist
which i seem i am i'm acknowledging that
foreign corporations are attempting to
buy us out they're they're squat
attempting to squander our
our wealth but i mean that doesn't mean
we can't change it
seize control well they want to make
money but so do why so competing
interests
not too not too crazy of a concept i
think we can work it out to go back to
the point i was saying about the the
food and fuel stuff is that
i think if it really got to the point
where in the u.s we're in short supply
for food and we're not in a position to
do foreign aid and send food food
anywhere else
these other countries
that are smaller
i don't think are as likely to
internally implode
they might yeah when there's no food and
it's due to the corruption of your
government you get a revolution when
there's no food to the foreign war the
leader can rally you and say they're
stealing our food then they can justify
invasion of a foreign country to get
food steal it from the neighbors the u.s
being so large though
i think the u.s implodes
small country sure small state sure
big country not so much well we got
mexico
do you think we're gonna go to war with
mexico i think maybe pillage them
unfortunately like uh california and
texas there's not gonna be california
and texas agreeing like we need to you
know go to mexico and get food and
california texas texas is going to be
like california's got the food
california's got all the food california
is going to leverage that against
everybody in the country we do have a
lot of food
oh yeah it's like a third isn't it we
have a ton of food in the central valley
we don't have great water um
infrastructure so that's a real problem
colorado says uh probably not even just
colorado but arizona nevada they say
we're we want food you want the water
that comes from our states without
without a federal government enforcing
these treaties what do you do
southern california exists only because
the colorado colorado river water oh
yeah and so if that gets cut off
bye-bye los angeles in san diego oh no
there you go then what they'll do is
they'll divert delta water
from the water from the delta north of
california to the south to compensate
which would turn which
would uh cause a massive influx of salt
water into the delta killing all of the
farms in the in in the bay area
and it would
if only california's government had
built water reservoirs 30 years ago like
everyone said they should we're known
for a ton of horrible policies but i
promise you that we have more horrible
policies that you guys have never heard
of it's actually it's
it's a giant it's like a layer cake of
failure oh yeah man
their rolling blackouts are coming yeah
uh what are they doing they're going to
do water rationing soon fuel rationing
again
second or third water rationing since
i've lived in california okay i don't
want to sound like a total idiot bimbo
but like
you're like next to the ocean right yes
so
can't you just take the salt out yeah
there are desalination plants and it's
doable it's not very cost effective yet
but that technology is also like they're
trying to improve it and i'm sure that
if we were in a real serious crunch and
the dot you know was turned off you
would see that you know propel rapidly
i'm not i'm not convinced california can
make it to be honest um i'm not sad
about it the level of corruption and
mismanagement is so intense that i'm not
convinced that in a real crisis people
would come together to solve it okay so
what if california collapses before
texas secedes
you think that might
you think that might change people's
attitudes about secession if they see or
just politics in general and the turmoil
if they see
the i think it might exacerbate
the issues we're the 11th largest
economy in the world in california and
if that collapsed that would be well
actually you would feel that globally oh
yeah there's your there's your global
issue in you would see that like
impacting the entire world there's a so
in order to make the desalination plants
work you need a lot of energy yes where
is the energy going to come from i guess
all the subsidy nuclear power plants we
shut down that's right what if they use
the salt from the ocean to boil to get
the heat to produce the electricity to
desalinate the ocean water to get more
salt to boil burn the salt yeah they
have these giant magnetic they have
thorium nuclear reactors where they heat
up salt and melt it and then it's
thorium salts though not just so that's
something different okay molten salt
what they'll do is they call it mirror
they have these mirror rays and they
focus the the light at the center tower
which is containing salt the salt melts
and then overnight it stays molten so it
produces boils water and just massive
amounts of steam power they have to
build those yeah i don't think
california is functional enough to build
those in a crisis
well no they got to start building them
now
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you